amit is with us in buffalo new york hey
eamon what's up
hi dave thank you for taking my call
sure
how can we help um so
so i had a question about uh finances so
i'll explain the situation uh me and my
wife uh
were both residents my wife graduated
residency
last year i'll be graduating this year
so during our residency we were able we
had whatever money we were able to save
we invested it it's a small amount of
money so i was okay doing it but
with my wife getting a new job and me
graduating and soon to get a new job the
amount of salary we have
uh i find it difficult handing that
amount of money
so my question was like when should i
get a financial uh advisor because i
have talked to a few people
uh but i i just i'm not able to trust
them but at the same time i'm afraid
handling that much amount of money which
i have never seen in my life good for
you
you're being very wise on a whole lot of
fronts
so here's what the mistake that um
that a lot of people fall into and it
sounds like you're starting to
and it'll solve both of your problems
sometimes people want a financial
advisor in their head they meet that
means they have to take over and run
their life and
we have to trust them
instead i use a a a financial
broker to do investments with
but i make the decisions and the way i
make the decisions is his job is to
present options to me
ideas to me and to teach me something i
didn't know before
and so much like you've studied in your
medical career to learn to be an expert
in that
you won't have to study nearly as hard
on money it's not that complicated
uh but you're gonna have to learn a few
basic things uh from a good uh financial
from a good investment broker or
investment advisor and they say they are
advising you they're not telling you
they're not it's not a babysitter you're
not turning your money over to them and
just hope it works out
they're saying this is advice and with
advice means you're going to learn a
little bit okay i don't understand that
and by the way the rule is you don't
work with a financial advisor
that doesn't have the heart of a teacher
if they have the heart of a salesman
their slimy run
if you feel like you need to have a
shower after you met with them run
uh and the other rule is don't put money
in anything you don't understand and
then you don't end up with being one of
those broke doctors
and broke doctors are there's more of
those than there are broke musicians
right that's that's what my fear is
because on your show you'd say that
doctors have dr
you know they do uh so that that's what
i'm afraid about that you know i
responded the money that i earned and
and that's why i'm looking for a
financial advisor at the same time
i have talked to a few people and i i
just i just have difficulty trusting
them with my money yeah you don't trust
them with your money you trust them to
teach you
because you trust you
yes
right and you must trust what dave just
told you let's just rewind what he said
you should be writing this down going
okay wait a second i'm in control if the
if the financial advisor gets frustrated
with you and they don't want to teach
you and explain
the questions that you've got you don't
understand the financial move that dave
said then don't do it
and you get to interview several people
you need to be meeting with some smart
investor pros yeah
collectivelysolutions.com click smart
vester at ramseysolutions.com and
that'll help you line up with someone
that has the heart of a teacher now
here's the other thing i don't want to
squander my money you said now let me
make sure you mean you don't want to
make a bad investment that you didn't
understand in it and lose the money is
that what you mean
correct yes okay not squander it like
i'm going to overspend and be
undisciplined hold on
no no
both of us are quite frugal
so i'm not worried about that i'm
worried about like if i put in the wrong
investment and i lose that one yeah
exactly because you know sometimes i've
run into and you were not saying this
but just for the sake of our audience
sometimes i run into someone who comes
into a lot of money
and uh uh sometimes i someone who's very
young for instance in uh in the music
world here in nashville they become very
popular and they got a lot of money all
of a sudden they don't have the maturity
to control the situation and that's a no
one can give you that that's called
growing up but you've already got that
obviously okay so we're frugal we're not
going to overspend we're not going to do
something stupid but you don't want
someone you know like i've heard people
say stuff like well i called my
financial advisor and he told me i
couldn't buy a car
well it's not his job to tell me whether
i can buy a car or not i'm going to
decide if i'm buy a freaking car i put
the money in the dadgum account i can
decide i'm a big boy i can decide i'm a
grown man i can look at the numbers and
go i can afford this car i can't afford
this car i don't need to ask someone's
permission to do crap with my money
that's right and so that's when you
that's when you handed it over and
somehow you've gotten someone who's
babysitting you and that is not what you
do that's how people get screwed that's
how they lose all their money and they
make a lot of money and they end up with
none so here's the trick don't put money
in something you don't understand don't
work with anyone in the financial world
real estate agents insurance agents uh
investment brokers estate planners
tax people don't work with anyone in the
financial world that does not have the
heart of a teacher
my poor tax guy has to explain our
infinitely confident complicated tax
returns enough that i i'm not just
signing him because he put him in front
of me and that's the key dave still has
the power and and i'm you have the power
as a doctor here would be the analogy
i'm sure you've had somebody show you
how to use a medical device before and
you don't use it on a patient until you
know that you know that you know that
you know how to use it and you have the
same control i'm not going to do that
until i understand how to use it you are
in control here you're not giving over
any control and i love your spirit but
again there should not be a spirit of
fear here go to ramseysolutions.com
interview three five seven smartvestor
pros until you get a good feel a good
chemistry and that they're willing to
explain things to you because as dave
said he doesn't sign on the tax form
until he understands what he's signing
yeah so amy you you can just pile up the
cash that's true too
if that's all you understand until you
understand more